I'm at the stage in my career in life
when there's nothing I'd like to see
more than an even older actor it gives
me hope I look at Eli and think hey I
could do this for another 30 40 years
I've known Eli for oh god I don't know
it's many years and and I've admired him
for many more he has an incredible
warmth humor and humanity but tonight we
honored his life achievements as an
actor and I have heard Eli referred to
as a character actor I think that's
meant to describe an actor who
customarily plays supporting roles but
really we're all character actors or at
least striving to be one it makes no
difference whether his character is the
lead or supporting Eli brings the same
craft dedication and artistry to the
challenge his drive has always been to
do the best for the film never for
himself his body of work is a testament
to his range and accomplishment and I
congratulate Eli I'm this honor and I
congratulate the Academy for making a
statement that while we appreciate our
biggest stars we also celebrate our
greatest actors
[Music]
just one personal note before we look at
some highlights of this extraordinary
career Eli
now that we're going up for the same
parts I hope I hope we can still remain
friends you know maybe you were a little
more right for the Ghost Rider but that
role in Wall Street was perfect for me I
would have killed to that
you